en arménie le président refuse de
limoger le chef de l'armée comme le
souhaite le premier ministre ce jeudi
nicole patine yann la limogé une
décision qui devait donc être validée
par le chef de l'état arménien en tout
cas la situation reste tendue
là bas des milliers
personnes continuent de défiler dans la
capitale pour demander la démission de
du premier ministre donc nicole patxi
nian qui est contesté depuis la défaite
militaire face à l'azerbaïdjan dans le
haut-karabagh celui qui a trahi la
patrie qui a trahi notre peuple doit
démissionner jusque-là personne pas un
président à un dirigeant n'avait traité
le peuple arménien de façon aussi
méprisables je ne connais pas une seule
personne raisonnable qui le soutiennent
c'est juste un démagogue
mais le gouvernement turc
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
arménienne
le gouvernement turc soutient une force
politique arménienne nous sommes
rassemblés ici dans ce but nous ne
partirons pas tant qu'il n'aura pas
signer sa démission
tant que le président n'aura pas
ordonner sa démission et qu'on ne l'aura
pas traduit en justice comme traîtres à
la patrie
il occupe un poste si élevé il doit
servir son peuple
servir son pays